welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
always appreciate when he stops by
certainly when college football is as
lit as it currently is and also bleeding
into what might be going on in coach
searching in the National Football
League
Bruce Feldman of Fox Sports and the
athletic and also yesterday part of the
Big Ten Network screw at the Rose Bowl
good to see you sir to see you happy new
year all right happy New Year to you too
so let's start with your tweet I'm
hearing that the Browns of strong
interest in former Ohio State head coach
Urban Meyer / sources I give you the
floor yes for multiple people have told
me this the question is gonna be how
interested is his Urban Meyer I mean
remember this is a guy who grew up in
Ohio you know really had a admiration
for Paul Brown I think there's some
element there that would say okay nobody
else has been able to fix this I've won
everywhere I've been I'm a Hall of Fame
caliber coach the the the other
challenges though and I think there's
what's out there
his health issue is real you know for
people who thought oh that's something
that's real and the stress you have from
being a TV guy as opposed to stress you
haven't even closed close and certainly
again Urban's used to having five at
every position not just five draft
choices for five spots per year
potentially or seven you know if you
don't trade any of them away or the fact
is that you know the Browns just had six
wins and that was sorely disappointing
he's used to having six wins before you
know October sometimes you know I'm
obviously I'm exaggerating so um how
interested do you think he will listen
the the the things here is and I would
think this could relate to the Dallas
Cowboys potentially as well you both
have situations where you have
quarterbacks that I think he's very
familiar with in the case of dak
Prescott obviously his protege Dan
Mullen found him developed him
everything in the case of Baker Mayfield
remembers a couple years ago Baker
Mayfield planted the flag in the middle
of the stadium you know the the
challenges is I think again I don't
think you for him to go back into
college football was one thing for him
to go back into NFL some
hasn't done before really and has it's
not like he's worked in the league I
mean we're talking about Matt rule
probably the last time I was here Matt
rule at least has been you know was with
the Giants for a season I don't know I
mean everything I've always kind of felt
from from working at Fox this year
especially with being on some calls with
urban is he genuinely has a passion for
what he is doing right now and he I mean
he's really committed to that
Aiki I don't think that's fake I think
it's real but I had the same talking
there's certain elements of the
competition in certain elements of those
things you can't replicate hey look I've
seen both Bruce Feldman here in the Rich
Eisen show
I've been around Mariucci for gosh now
15 years pretty much and anytime I was
with him on a Thursday night football
field at a game and he loves what he's
doing right now and his passion is
committed as as anybody but when when
the ball snapped his hands are on his
knees he's bent over and he is talking
to refs he's talking to coaches I saw
the end of the Fiesta Bowl they cut to a
shot of bourbon and he looked just like
Mariucci does during games you know what
her coach you're always degree I was at
the SEC title game a few weeks ago Lee
Corso
who was 86 eighty something the same
thing he's there hands on knees like I
mean you can see the energy in them in
that and he's been far removed from from
being being a coach for 20-plus years
Urban Meyer by the way it's probably as
competitive a guy as college football
has seen sure so maybe take it to the
nth degree but again I think the health
issues are real and I think you know I
think there's probably some times and is
knowing I've had this conversation
whether I don't want to portray that I
have but I think from talking to people
who have been close to him I think
there's a lot of times where urban may
feel this way about something and then
the next day may feel come you know
rethink it and reevaluate it so you know
I do think he will listen but again the
Browns have all sorts of things going on
well to the point where it Bruce Feldman
here on the Rich Eisen show Matt rule
said I'm not interested don't you know
go talk to other people
I'm or I'm going to talk to other people
not
and that was I think that report came
out in the morning that John Dorsey went
and had the meeting with the haslums
during which smoke came out and
everybody's saying well this could be it
for Dorsey too and it was and I have no
idea what in the world is happening
there but rule knew enough or was
skeptical about enough for him to say I
might leave Baylor but not for you yeah
and so why would a band not have an
issue with the thing wouldn't have an
issue like that I I don't want to say
you know to speak on my role speaking to
somebody close to him and I'd reported
this I guess a couple days ago now he's
by out sizable it's not weird it's not
off the charts but it is a big buyout
everything I've been told is he and his
family really liked it there the
situation they have he's making now in
his new deal top ten money in college
football what I was told by somebody
close to him is it has to be almost a
perfect situation for him to leave what
he has and I think he will be very very
careful about to get into a situation
where he's not fully comfortable and
confident in the leadership around him
well what about the merit ish ownership
they're not going anywhere
obviously Dave gentlemen might need to
look at listings
if things don't work out the next year
or two but he is staying for the moment
daniel Jones quarterback that is there
how do you think was from that
organization he's from that area if the
New York Football Giants come knocking
on the door of anybody that I know from
from that area they're gonna think of
themselves as a young kid saying how do
I turn something like this down yeah and
I think that's very that's gonna be very
attractive and I think it probably would
be hard to say no I honestly think
there's a lot of positives to the
Panthers leadership situation that I
think could be intriguing to him also
but you know what again I think he's
dealing from a position of strength
because he knows there's a lot of people
who looked at and go you can't win a
national title at Baylor and on the
surface right now it doesn't look like
you can but Matt rule has done stuff
already that nobody thought they'd be
playing for a big 12 title the way they
did this year
I mean as far as I like first of all I
was kind of shocked he took that job he
could have been the Oregon head coach
they ended up hiring Willie Taggart and
he ended up instead wanted to take the
Baylor job he took it he's done he's
pretty much everything right for them
and I think he's built something he's
evaluated really well so I don't think
it's gonna be people are like well he's
interviewed before with the NFL the last
two years in fact I don't think it's a
slam dunk he bolts but I think he looks
at these these are really good
situations these are things I have to
look at and whereas the Browns I think
it's probably something he was like you
know what that's not lining up the way I
need it to Bruce Feldman here on the
Rich Eisen show and finishing up with
the NFL coaching search carousel and how
it might connect to college football as
of our conversation you and I sitting
here Jerry Jones and Jason Garrett
apparently having a third meeting
together since the end of the season and
in the NFL just like many sports what
fills a vacuum certainly when something
defies explanation
is rumor innuendo or even conspiracy so
I have no idea why this is taking so
long on what appears to be so inevitable
is there any way shape or form because
you're not there's no rush
right now with Dallas that Lincoln
Reilly's sitting out there and they know
that he isn't going anywhere to somebody
else in Oklahoma and that this tube plus
that two equals four is there any way
that that's possible Bruce it's possible
I'd be so I'd be a little surprised if
Lincoln Riley took an NFL job at this
point and just from talking to people
really close to him recently I would be
surprised I wouldn't be shocked but I
would be surprised at this point you
know I think people looked at the way
the the Peach Bowl came out the other
day you know LSU beat them worse than
nobody the worst loss Lincoln Riley had
in his three years at Oklahoma going
into that game was only about 11 points
they got blown off the field the other
day and they have got to recruit better
especially on defense
I think they
they made some some progress in terms of
the big picture and obviously to me the
difference from going Baker and Cuyler
then to jaylen Hertz who was a different
kind of quarterback and they lost a
bunch of offensive lineman around I
think it was they had a really good year
considering they got a little better on
defense they have to get way better on
defense what if the Dallas Cowboys knock
I mean that's the Dallas Cowboys right I
mean even urban it would be answering
that telephone call so I don't give your
Lincoln riling you look at this and you
say okay I I work for the best ad in
college sports and Joe Castiglione I
have developed my staff where I'm very
comfortable with the direction it's
going in you know I've come I've come
made the playoffs I've come close in the
year they almost beat Georgia and that
was with Baker out here at the Rose Bowl
right I think he knows that he can win a
national title at Oklahoma and I don't
think he was gonna walk away from that
at this point because I think he knows
I'm young enough the NFL is always gonna
be there and again you know Jimmy
Johnson won a national title before he
left Miami to go to the Cowboys and
obviously the timing has to be right and
that was a unique situation I don't know
I don't think Lincoln leaves the leaves
at on this I just that's just my hunch
that's not something that that he's told
me but I just don't think he would Fox
college football analyst the Athletics
Bruce Feldman here on the rich Johnson
show what's at the top of your notebook
whatwhat am I not asking you that that
maybe has come to the fore or over the
last couple weeks to you you know we've
talked about and we both live in Los
Angeles obviously we've talked a lot
about USC and clay Helton and there's a
lot of people were very incredulous that
clay Helton still is the head coach well
certainly after what Iowa did to the
time solutely Iowa you know credit to
Kirk Ferentz team but they they whipped
that team bad in Southern California
obviously no less at the Holiday Bowl I
don't think people realize and this is
from some of my reporting the economics
of what it would take to make a coaching
change there I think we talked about
this the last most year that the money
buyout lies with the staff and clay
Helton would be bigger than it's been
reported the money for the change we
would actually and we're talking about
could be 50
million dollars to make not just a
buyout not just change the staff Brown
because the staff also had multiple year
deals there were some things that Lynn
Swann had done that probably not a lot
of other 80s wouldn't have gotten
attached to the way they did what do you
mean which is multi-year deals for
assistance not just you know for clay
we're talking about fully guaranteed
deals those things are significant and
again it comes back to a little bit of
who you're gonna get
afterwards I don't know if there was any
I don't think there was any slam dunk
this guy is gonna come in here we make
this coaching change we eat a lot of
money that we'd have to eat to make this
coaching change again it's to bring in a
new staff and everything that would take
we're talking about 45 50 million
dollars well I mean what about making a
Jimmy Iovine field at masterpiece
stadium you know I mean yeah they're who
they gonna hire then I mean who's the
coach that those guys would want to put
in their stead Steven Spielberg locker
room or I mean us he's got people right
yeah but they're also then you have to
make a smart decision going forward
especially with a school that by the way
has all sorts of PR issues and all sorts
of scandal problems I don't know they're
digging out of so they're trying to make
and I do think the new president Carol
folt I think there is substance there I
don't think that's lip service I do
think she cares about you know a moral
component to this that and look in clay
Helton credit he is a very upstanding
guy in terms of the representative of
that and you know if you're gonna try to
talk about morals and ethics you know
and then you blow him out of there and
then hire somebody or like who has a lot
of baggage then you look like the the
biggest hypocrite there is before I let
you go
I will use my real estate with Bruce
Feldman for this the state troopers that
bring the coaches out to midfield for
interviews and or handshakes what gives
with that what gives loose I mean it
just it it just seems to me that there's
more and more I do not know where you go
with this question
let's say I mean you know those state
troopers by the way up there the haze
for them do we know like is this Nick
Saban's personal state troopers that go
with him wherever he goes for Alabama
and this police officer that's with Jim
Harbaugh yeah some of those guys are
with them all the time obviously a state
trooper Alabama's different than
probably in the Outback Bowl there's
Florida you know probably State Patrol
who's also on the sideline but there
will be a guy there was a policeman that
was Miami's guy for a long time edu dak
he was a foreman back up off in slime I
think it was like three or four national
title rings Bobby Bowden's guy has
national title rings you know I'm sure I
mean look at curvy smart he had a
wishbone
he had a wishbone behind him yeah I
probably roll up the good thing she got
in there yeah Hollywood just helped were
way past those I see no matter no matter
what kind of hardware they're packaged
holly will find a way oh but a lot of
them I don't know about in this case
with Georgia there but I look I spent
the last couple of weeks around LSU now
I know one of the law-enforcement guys
who's around there he's you know they're
part of the program Oh Joan brings him
on over he'll be at the he'll be at the
he'll be bananas oh yeah I'm sure yeah
coaches aren't going to switch anything
like that no in fact at one point I
remember seeing this particular
policeman like you know they're it's
like they're part of the deal because I
think there has to be a comfort level I
think also you gotta remember there are
hundred fifty people who are now with
these programs and I think if there's
somebody who is in security I think they
need to know okay this guy's I haven't
seen him before what's he doing around
here of course what's this person doing
around here so I think there's a little
bit of that all right
couple quick hitters for you before I
let you completely go here to on Monday
says what I think too is I mean I I'm
guessing right now because I'm surprised
as dragged out anytime I think it's a
player with an injury especially one and
I know you know his his insurance
situation with that I think two is gonna
still come out because look if he
doesn't come out now Trevor Lawrence is
coming out next year
Justin fields is coming out next year -
I'm not saying - is scared of those guys
but Trevor Lawrence is like looks like
first pick of the draft guy and Justin
fields
talented - we heard Trevor Lawrence as
it was reporting that he's got a five
million dollar insurance policy if he
can't make it to the NFL healthy's at
the same thing for to hear the seven
think it would be more than that so
there's obviously a couple of different
categories there's the loss of value and
then there's I would not at all be
surprised if if Trevor Lawrence has a
bigger policy the bigger policy than
that and then last one big surprise
there any surprise coaching surprises
what do you think what do you think
would be the most likely surprise in
college football the the most likely
surprise it was in that big of a
surprise would be Matt rule leaving I
just think that that on the surface that
feels like it's there are real options
he's obviously investigated before I
think he'll make a very sound decision
the wild-card one is the one we talked
about in the beginning which is Urban
Meyer I mean my hunch is he won't he
won't take anything this year and he
will stay in TV but I don't think
anybody knows exactly what urban is
gonna do because I just think you know
we saw this when he was at Florida we've
seen it at times where you know he can
be all over the place for some of these
thoughts cuz I think I think there's
just a lot to it and it's not it's not
simple with him because of the health
issues because of a lot of factors with
him would you be surprised if my guy
goes Mariucci know Harbaugh I'll say
that just directly through the front
door if he went to go be the giant head
coach so he lives next door to his
parents his grant his parents get to
hang with their grandchildren ultimate
competitor right and that helmet right
now he's got a lot of you know it's got
a lot of other people's paint on it you
know you
how does he leave Michigan with job
undone oh I mean I mean you know III
don't know that's why even a white flag
I think that doesn't seem that's not in
line with anything I've ever heard about
Jim Harbaugh I agree with you but I you
know money's talks and no no I mean it's
easy for me to say this but not my money
he's got plenty of money I you know like
generational wealth he does not need to
go chase some other job or anything like
that
like the question is do I really think I
can get this done I think you can I mean
obviously you can just take a look at
LSU I mean you know I'm gonna go to head
coach to his credit has made a lot of
changes that a lot most other head
coaches aren't willing to come to terms
with he makes those changes and he I
think he sometimes knows to have the
discipline to go against some of his own
instincts initially that might be
because he's he's smarter than that well
the reason why I bring up LSU is I bring
up LSU because they are you know or were
secondary to Alabama in their conference
they were some organization that was
still always looking for an above
average exceptional quarterback and look
what's happened in the last few months
just period months I've never seen
somebody go from what burrow was last
year to currently right now yeah which
is probably can change the greatest
college quarterbacks in this season that
anybody's ever surrender so if it can
happen at in LSU it can happen it may
five factors that happen to do what's
going on LSU I think one was this was
the evolution of the head coach and how
he runs the program - he made a very
very savvy hire when nobody else knew
who Joe Brady was to help very spark the
offense three I think he needed the
infrastructure around Joe Brady with
Stephens mayor the office corner how he
can manage it and also the support
people who were there and then he needed
Joe he needed Joe burrow to be you know
this guy who isn't is incredibly smart
very athletic and accurate you have
those three things where it's like
having a one of the guys on their staff
had you know it told me he reminds him
of Peyton Manning this is a guy who
worked with Peyton Manning at Tennessee
Tommy Moffett the strength coach another
ground their staff is John Robinson you
know the legendary coach John Robinson
I've seen him practice he was like he
reminds me of Joe Montana you know those
are heavy names so I think you know
that's shaped Patterson was a good
college quarterback he didn't turn out
to be the five-star guy so was Joe Parr
oh I'm so turned out to be something and
I guess this is where it may be I'm not
saying it
I think there are some things where if
whether it's diamond in the rough or
what not but Joe burrows and tangibles
it seems like we're off the charts
that's all I heard about Shay Patterson
when he was coming off the campus at Ole
Miss here you know you'd heard he had a
quick release I don't know if you heard
the intangible stuff almost talking to
the wrong people then I don't know if
you have a special quarterback I mean
then it can especially if it's if he's
in the right structure and everything
else and look maybe McCaffrey will be
that guy for Michigan I don't know Bruce
thanks at the time happens your team
thanks for coming in here well definite
ID love to have you back on or in
however you wish before the National
Champion afterwards as well all right
Bruce Feldman at Bruce Feldman CFB on
Twitter at Bruce Feldman Fox on
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app